I wonder if there's gonna be any Red
Pony with you [ __ ] hey what's up guys
and welcome to dark souls modded so
there's a few things to note about what
you're watching the first is that luring
the bone wheels over here
it's an amazing plan and absolutely
nothing will go wrong even though more
bone will skeletons just came around the
corner now it'll be fine it'll be easy
spoiler I died so this is the permanent
grave Lord mod it's one of the simpler
mods all it does is permanently infect
every area of your game with red
phantoms as if you are being grave
loaded and if that gets your sick
twisted masochistic mind excited then
this is the mod for you I almost wasn't
gonna make a video on it but my
playthrough of the catacombs was really
fun and I actually think it's neat
playing through new game+ the way the
dev is intended and yes the devs did
intend for you to go through this hell
grave loading activates on New Game+ but
unfortunately the Covenant was glitchy
and broken so not many got to experience
these wonderful encounters until now I
think I'm gonna need some music for this
[Music]
a so wala was running through Satan's
playground you might have noticed
something else I'm actually wearing the
same armor as the Dark Souls 2 mascot
well almost this is a texture recolor of
the Giants helm wander a chest and
Domino's leggings as well as the great
lord great sword and the crest shield
Dark Souls 2 is still five months away
and this helps to ease the pain speaking
of pain [ __ ] that guy I can confidently
say or at least I think that there's no
harder enemy every time I died no matter
what I try he's just really hard to
predict but maybe you guys don't think
so I reckon you guys should give it a
try a guide to installing the mod will
be in the description if you're
interested so in case it wasn't obvious
enough this isn't just the grave loaded
game this is also like a New Game+ 3 so
if you download this mod you can expect
it to be slightly easier than this it's
not going to be a cakewalk by any means
but it won't be as heartbreakingly
depressing as I'm making it same a
really good challenge run would be to
kill every grave Lord you see I know a
guy called Rubicon is currently doing a
playthrough of the mod with those rules
you should check out his video in the
description if you're more into the
let's play sort of thing rather than
this showcase type format on the topic
of playthroughs I'm actually planning on
doing something interesting in the near
future
so I've showcased three mods so far
maybe you've seen them all and I reckon
it would be entertaining to combine all
three what do you guys think a
first-person hyper aggressive perma
gravelord run would be pretty unique
I'll put a link to the Dark Souls modded
playlist at the end of the video so if
you want to check it out you really
should all of these mods really make the
game feel fresh again and they'll bring
out some new great experiences to this
two year old game and speaking of a 2
year old game I'm really good with my
segues today I have always found it
amazing that there's this lively
community around the game after all this
time I mean look at my channel I only
started when the PC version was released
and I'm making videos for almost a
hundred thousand people now
I actually have an awesome video ready
to be released as soon as I hit a
hundred K sub so look forward to that
depending on when you're watching this
it actually might already be out but if
it isn't feel free to subscribe so you
don't miss it it's something new for
this channel it's the best thing I've
worked on in months and it's something
I'd love to do more often anyway thanks
for watching this short showcase if the
other video is out feel free to check it
out and if it's not out feel free to
subscribe and look forward to my next
video
cheers guys I'll see you next time by
definition only the coward is capable of
the highest heroism for the coward
fights despite his weak nature Prince Al
and the son of King allant
travels to the bow latarian palace under
the name Ostrava in order to hide his
true identity the scourge has devastated
the kingdom and as the player sets out
to kill the arch demons Ostrava fights
through the bullet Arion palace with a
sole intent